elevando la atención con washington
después de que el presidente
estadounidense joe biden denominar a
cuba como un estado fallido homólogo en
la habana miguel díaz canel respondió
con un ataque directo si el presidente
joe biden tuviera sincera preocupación
humanitaria por el pueblo cubano podría
eliminar las 243 medidas aplicadas por
el presidente de donald trump incluidas
las más de 50 impuestas cruelmente
durante la pandemia como primer paso
para el cese del bloqueo el domingo
estallaron en cuba las mayores protestas
antigubernamentales en décadas que
derivaron en enfrentamientos violentos
dejando un muerto y decenas de heridos
la represión contra los manifestantes
así como los cortes de internet
desataron una ola de condenas
internacionales este viernes human rigth
watch denunció que hay cerca de 400
detenidos y desaparecidos y naciones
unidas- hizo un llamado para su
liberación la alta comisionada de
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos michelle bachelet está pidiendo
a las autoridades cubanas que liberen
sin demora a todos los detenidos por
ejercer sus derechos a la libertad de
reunión pacífica o la libertad de
opinión y expresión el grito de libertad
para cuba
solo con fuerza en la isla fue replicado
por miles de cubanos en el exilio desde
washington hasta argentina también
partidarios del gobierno cubano salieron
a las calles de chile o bolivia